augusta lunar dit elle est journaliste
indépendante au brésil bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
que pensez vous de cette réaction du
président ne risque-t-il pas de se
mettre à dos la population brésilienne
avec ses prises de position alors
bolsenheim des filles mais une partie de
la population un dos à chaque fois qui
fait ce genre de déclarations publiques
il ne se gêne pas de faire de dire ce
genre de propos il ya plusieurs
brésiliens qui se met dans toutes les
grandes villes du brésil qui se mettent
sur leurs fenêtres et commence à taper
sur des casseroles mais en même temps il
a le soutien d'une partie de la
population quoi qu'ils disent
actuellement nous savons que plus de 30%
entre 30 % et 34 % des brésiliens le
soutien même avec la pandémie a dans
l'état dans laquelle elle se trouve
actuellement avec plus de 10 millions de
personnes contaminées et plus de 260
mille victimes du corry 19 alors où on a
des chiffres quand même assez dramatique
un prêt de 11 millions de cas et plus de
260 me demande où kevin aubry elle sans
échec de l'immunité collective ou bien
encore un échec politique de la part du
président le rappelle qu'il continue
plus ou moins à nier la gravité de la
pandémie
où exactement il s'agit clairement d'un
échec de la gestion de gerbe au sonar au
fait face pardon à cette crise sanitaire
il faut rappeler qui s'est toujours
opposé publiquement aux mesures
sanitaires ont recommandé par le ms
comme par exemple la fermeture des
services non essentiels il a toujours
dit que le pays ne peut pas s'arrêter
il a fait des nombreuses apparitions en
public quand il était contaminée par le
coït 19 d'ailleurs parfois ils ne
portaient pas le masque ils ne
respectaient souvent la distanciation
social il ya encore comme vous avez vu
il a déclaré publiquement qu'il faut
qu'on arrête de se plaindre et de
pleurer alors que nous sommes en pleine
deuxième vague dévastatrice et donc
comme vous avez dit depuis le début de
la pandémie ball sonar où il n'a cessé
de minimiser la dent
eurosic et du virus il a déjà déclaré
que c'était une petite grippe
le résultat est là devant nous nous
sommes un des pays le plus touché par le
corps et 19 après les états unis
alors vous êtes en directeur de rio quel
est l'état d'esprit des brésiliens
aujourd'hui est ce qui te sont un peu
lassé des restrictions à bout de nerfs
je dirais que les brésiliens sont
beaucoup moins inquiet face à cette
deuxième vague si l'on comparé à la
première vague ici au brésil on n'a pas
vraiment l'impression que nous
traversons une pandémie
s'il en sort dans la rue malgré le
record de cas de contamination de nombre
de victimes du convive 19 et le pauvre
veut d'ailleurs qui est instaurée
uniquement le soir et les week-ends mais
en fait l'isolément social n'existe
pratiquement plus ici au brésil n'a
vraiment jamais existé il n'a vraiment
jamais été respecté les transports en
commun sont bondées car malheureusement
les gens n'ont pas le choix que d'aller
travailler
le port de masques de moins en moins
respectée mais surtout ce qui est
difficile c'est de sensibiliser une
grande partie de la population si notre
chef d'état encourage les brésiliens ne
pas respecter les mesures sanitaires et
s'il déclare très souvent quasiment tous
les jours d'ailleurs que la pandémie est
une hystérie d'exagération et que le
pays ne peut pas s'arrêter
et pour parler de la campagne vaccinale
dans le pays pourquoi est-elle si dante
oui exactement le manque de vaccins et
de plus un peu ce criant ici au brésil
plusieurs grandes villes du pays dont
salvador et salvador de bahia pardon et
rio dé janeiro ont dû interrompre depuis
plusieurs jours la vaccination
la principale raison c'est parce que le
brésil n'a pas les moyens de produire
toutes les étapes de fabrication des
vaccins et dépend de l'importation des
intrants pharmaceutiques qui ont eux été
livrés en retard et surtout parce que le
gouvernement brésilien dispose seulement
de deux types de vaccins las 3e et
caicos ford ce qui met la stran eca et
le court en attaque ce qui met le pays
dans une situation de vulnérabilité
sanitaire résultats jusqu'à présent
seuls
millions de brésiliens ont reçu leurs
premières doses soit à peine 3 % de la
population est justement cette
population est ce que vous l'avez jugé
réticente face au vaccin
oui oui exactement des études récentes
fait un dessin montre que seulement 22
pour cent pendant que 22% le brésilien
ne souhaite pas se faire vacciner bon ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle
ces chiffres sont de plus en plus
réduits avant l'année dernière un tiers
de la population ne souhaitait pas se
faire vacciner et ça est dû aux
nombreuses fausses informations qui ont
été diffusées surtout par le président
qui a déjà dit que nous pouvions avoir
des graves effets secondaires comme se
transformer dans un dans des animaux
bizarres dont il a dit ça publiquement
et c'est devenu même une blague
ici au brésil si on prend le vaccin on
peut devenir je sais pas un éléphant ou
des choses comme ça on se rappelle de
ses propos merci augusta lunardi d'avoir
répondu à toutes nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
indépendante au brésil
vous étiez avec nous en direct de rio
merci à vous